si vous êtes ici c'est peut-être que
vous faites partie des 50% des français
qui ont du mal à dormir il vous est
difficile de vous détendre avant de vous
coucher vous cogiter en pensant à votre
journée à votre emploi du temps du
lendemain il existe pourtant une
solution naturelle qui a fait ses
preuves depuis des générations
l'utilisation des plantes le fit aux
nuits en sachet à infuser un mélange
innovant de mélatonine l'hormone
naturelle du sommeil et de cinq plants
vous aide à vous endormir et bien dormir
alors ne pensez plus à rien et profiter
de cette séance de relaxation en
partenariat avec fit aux nuits le figaro
présente inspiration un podcast de
benjamin lubinski psy hypnothérapeute il
youtuber si vous n'avez pas eu
l'occasion d'écouter le dernier épisode
d'inspiration le podcast je vous invite
chaleureusement à le faire parce que
montanes a invité est un véritable au
compteur c'est quelqu'un qui sait avec
ces mots le timbre de sa voix son rythme
partager ses émotions son expérience son
monde intérieur
ce qu'il crée et cette séance elle est
née de cette rencontre
pourquoi ces images ces situations ces
expériences que je vais vous décrire je
ne sais pas ça fait partie je crois du
secret la créativité sait jamais d'où ça
vire exactement mais à la fin on se rend
compte que ça avait un sens alors
j'aimerais partager avec vous cette
séance
cette séance d'hypnose somnifères qui va
vous permettre de vous endormir
rapidement et vous sentir vraiment bien
vous n'avez absolument aucun effort à
faire sauf à commencer par bien vous
installer confortablement vous allonger
dans cette position que vous prenez
lorsque vous vous endormez une position
confortable
le plus éloigné possible de ses douleurs
ou de ces tensions de 6,2 larmes et à
poser votre attention sur un point est
absolument qu'un effort à faire ceglia
de doux et agréable dans l'hypnose
mais suffit de se laisser bercer par me
voir même un certain moment d'oublier
mes paroles de perdre une attention
consciente pour retrouver une
réceptivité inconsciente mais toujours
sans effort et un moment les yeux se
ferment pour entrer dans le sommeil de
l'hypnose un moment après le corps
s'endort tout à fait du sommeil de la
nuit dans une continuité quasiment
parfaite on va du conscient vers
l'inconscient au sommeil enfin 5
vous entendez les bruits autour de vous
peut-être ma voix qui va se préciser en
vous et par sa lenteur et par sa douceur
et par son rythme distiller petit à
petit du calme la sérénité du repos et
cette impression tous d'avoir envie de
dormir
pour cela est fort faire le moins
d'effort possible jeu se laisse porter
par me voir comme si je vous lise est
une histoire se laisser porter aussi par
les silences entre les mots par les
images les sensations les sons qui vont
naître en vous sans effort de la même
manière que les rêves s'installe dans le
sommeil se développe tout seul et bien
la rêverie de l'hypnose elle aussi se
développent de la même manière sans
effort naturellement à un niveau
inconscient et bien sûr là tout le temps
qu'il faut pour parvenir à cet état de
quiétude mais simplement le fait de
retrouver le soir pour vous endormir à
chaque fois que vous en avez besoin
ma voix cette séance et bien cela crée
un processus d'intériorisation
et en fonction de la hausse pause
l'attention le contact de l'air contre
le visage contre les mots tout bien le
contact de la couette ou des draps bien
d'autres sensations comme le poids du
corps
la chaleur du lit peu importe au fur et
à mesure l'esprit l'attention s'éloigne
de l'extérieur pour se développer vers
l'intérieur et rendre les sensations
interne plus forte
c'est la première étape à l'hypnose
ensuite un état inconscient léger et
doux à se développer se répandre
c'est pour ça que la respiration devient
plus lente plus régulière c'est pour ça
aussi que je vous invite à prendre de
ses inspirations profondes première puis
une deuxième à laisser votre respiration
sa profonde hier tout seul et pendant
que les pensées s'accroche se décrochent
s'accroche et ceux des gorges
pendant que les pensées se font se
défont forme d'autres formes d'autres
sous faure se forment et se reforme et
se déforment à nouveau la respiration se
fait plus profonde plus lente et plus
régulières comme la respiration d'un
d'armes
vous pouvez sentir cet air cal vrai vous
inspirer
qui vous faire ressentir d'autant plus
intensément la douce chaleur du lit
l'engourdissement bientôt du corps pour
aller vers l'île aux pies le sommeil est
ce pour ça que le corps se détend pour
les papas tranquillement a le sommeil de
l'hypnose puis le sommeil de la nuit
quatre ans et d'autres sensations
peuvent s'installer comme le poids du
corps lorsque l'esprit s'allège se met à
rêver
il laisse le corps pasquine animé
immobile ou dans une transe de plus en
plus profondes
cette lourdeur du corps bien sûr laisse
l'esprit plus léger et simple comme s'il
y avait une dissociation entre les deux
l'esprit porté dans les airs comme un
courant aérien serait m'avoir le corps
l'eau qui s'enfonce dans le lit et se
réfugie dans sa douce chaleur
et la protection du liet de la chambre
le corps lourd sur le lit au lit
immobile solidement ancré sur le ca le
sol de cette maison cet immeuble qui
vous protège vous entourent soulignement
créé sur la ville désormais plus
silencieuse et en dehors hui la ville
seulement créé sous la terre la terre
souligne mme ancré dans le système
solaire
sept ans nous dans les mobiles que nous
avions enfants ou bbc cette danse des
planètes et du soleil solidement
inscrits dans la galaxie ce chemin vers
les rêves l'univers solidement ancré
dans le temps et le temps solidement
ancrée en vous disent que vous en créez
de plus en plus en transe
pourquoi
cela nous rappelle cette sensation tout
ce que l'on a
avoir un animal endormi un chien mon
chat
il ya cette respiration de plus en plus
profondes mais aussi quelque chose de
très doux dans le visage de l'animal qui
dort et recroquevillée ou allongés
il ya quelque chose de communicatif
dans ce plaisir à dormir
et lorsque l'on caresse son chien son
chat parfois ils ouvrent les yeux pour
mieux les refermer ensuite et sans
dormir dans un sommeil plus profonds
comme pour entrer en transe davantage et
c'est comme si au travers de la caresse
on pouvait sentir se calme
ce bien-être
cette douceur du repos et du sommeil
comme si ils nous la transmettait
qu'il est doux de se laisser s'engourdir
un peu de rêvasser vous ce sentiment se
payer au contact d'un animal familier un
être proche de vous cette sensation
d'entrer dans quelque chose d'autre on
l'a aussi en regardant son enfant dormir
regardant la personne que l'on aime bien
simplement observant son propre corps
qui se détend et entrent de plus en plus
dans le sommeil de la transe de alors
que vous pensez s'accroche se décroche
l'or que faire ce faisant se faire
naître rien d'autre que ce que l'on
s'est fait alors même que vous avez
toujours plus que vous ne saviez que
vous saviez
1 est ce le faire mais maintenant s'il
ne l'était pas déjà depuis fin longtemps
vous êtes dans ce premier sommet et
qu'on appelle la transe cet état on se
met y est la respiration de plus en plus
lourde et régulière guidés par ma voix
vous accompagner dans une rêverie notre
ans de plus en plus profondes et parfois
quand les mots s'entremêlent
quand les phrases semble ou non parfois
devenir pas trop long mais ne pas avoir
de fin comme une sorte de ritournelles
de danse
une phrase sans début ni fin
une mélodie que l'on pourrait sifflet
toujours un infini si proches dans
l'inconscient et dans les songes des
rêves vous entrer davantage en transe le
corps repos et l'esprit engourdi aussi
tout en vous laisse porter vers le
sommeil de l'hypnose est peut-être
avez-vous déjà embarqué dans la lenteur
de mes phrases ce quelque chose de
magique que l'on peut trouver dans
certaines situations de quelque chose de
mystérieux qui nous endort sur le
soutiennent ont peur de sa façon de lire
lentement un conte une histoire une
nouvelle
son être régulier l'an serein et quelle
que soit l'histoire quel que soit le
compte les yeux semblaient plus lourd
l'esprit s'immobilisait et le corps qu'à
s'endormait auront de savoir sur mon
rendement régulier cela plaît
certainement déjà vécu avec un
professeur dans la voix un peu monocorde
ça fait le charles de vous endormir
[Musique]
loin de la culpabilité que l'on peut
avoir à ne pas suivre un cours ne pas
écouter un professeur
j'aimerais que au souveniez mieux encore
que vous reviviez la classe confié
et ce prof cet homme ou cette femme qui
parlait de cette matière qui lui tenait
certes à coeur mais son rythme régulier
la trop grande quantité d'informations
ce flot ininterrompu de mot vous donnez
l'impression vous donnez l'impression de
vous sentir plus lourd vous vous posiez
sur votre main et est devenu plus lourde
le corps avait du mal à rester assis les
bras avaient envie de s'allonger de tout
leur long sur la table et la tête de
sion fuir pour dormir tout à faire alors
pour éviter que cela ne se voie trop
vous mettiez votre main comme une sorte
de vase
pour contenir votre tête
les yeux n'étaient pas dues les
paupières se ferment de plus en plus les
yeux papillonnait de plus en plus vite
un certain moment vous rendiez compte
vous aviez oublié bien que vous ne
prêter plus attention
un moment dans la salle de classe le
corps déjà endormi atig et les esprits
engourdis et une partie de vous qui déjà
est une partie de vous qui déjà rêver
d'ailleurs
et alors si la pièce était un peu trop
chaude de chaleur humaine de ses
camarades autour de vous ou bien un
radiateur dans la chaleur danse se
répandait dans votre corps ils encourent
10 et encore davantage quelque chose
d'immobile s'installer dans votre corps
les pensées liés aux cures devenait plus
lourdes les oreilles oublier d'écouté
les yeux de voir et simplement cette
envie répressive de fermer les yeux et
de s'endormir tout à fait
ce petit je ne sais quoi de culpabilité
qui donnait à sow sommes encore plus de
plaisir de valeur et un charme
hypnotique qui vous envahit sans vous
laisser rejoindre les bras de morphée
alors monde hormis calme et étendu vous
n'entendiez plus rien vous mettiez à
rêver tout à fait devenant un autre ou
vous-même simple spectateur
qu'il était bon ce même volet autres à
main volé à la fatigue de la tension le
droit d'échapper à la laideur trop
d'informations
il ya tant de moments où tout semble
conspiré pour vous endormir
j'aimerais que votre inconscient fasse
revivre ces l'ombre pas de week end qui
semblaient s'éterniser
cette sensation lorsque le ventre tu es
trop plein c'est que peut-être un peu
trop de vin avaient un peu trop bégayé
les esprits et faire rougir les jours
tout simplement parce que ce déjeuner
sans fin et la régularité des paroles la
sensation d'être avec ces gens
connaissez si bien être entouré en
sécurité alors lorsque
on se dirige vers le salon le living
room pour ce soir pour être plus honnête
s'affaler sur un fauteuil un canapé le
corps est tellement lourd est satisfait
et laisse plus tellement fatigués on se
prend à somnoler sans même faire exprès
ou encore à bien manger
bury parler et plein de tout cela du
somnoler s'offrent le droit l'immobilité
au repos et au sommet il y aussi cette
sensation plaisante
lorsque on a beaucoup marché
peut-être sur une plage peut-être la mer
peut-être simplement dans une ville ou
un chemin de campagne que le corps ait
eu chaud ne serait ce que par l'effort
et que l'on s'autorise enfin à prendre
une pause peut-être à l'ombre peut-être
à profiter du soleil
peut-être pour boire un peu à l'eau si
tout d'un coup c'est toute la fatigue
pesante ne marche longue qui s'empare de
vous et les yeux se ferment toujours
plus facilement et c'est comme si l'on
devait utiliser toute la force de ses
bras pour empêcher les paupières de se
fermer définitivement sur un sommeil et
parfois on score de ce plaisir on
s'allonge dans l'herbe
quelque part par le porte
on sait tous à quelque chose on se
recroqueville sur soi même et le monde
or ce sommeil répressive la fatigue à
porte et qui emporte des pensées et les
son corps le repos et le sommeil
il ya aussi ces longs voyages l'arrière
d'une voiture lorsque le corps un peu
trop immobile le corps masser par les
vibrations de la voiture par le bruit
doux du moteur bruit blanc lorsque
l'esprit les yeux voix
des paysages se dérouler mais aussi les
lignes blanches s'interrompre commencé
d'une manière presque fini
lorsque on sent qu'on a pas besoin de
bouger la voiture bouge pour vous le
monde avec parce qu'on a un peu trop
chaud et que l'on s'enfonce un peu plus
dans les fauteuils de la voiture aussi
les yeux pique un peu les paupières se
faire
n'était pas on écoute simplement les
bruits autour bruit du moteur
peut-être le bruit sourd des voix
peut-être une émission à la radio de la
musique se laisse dériver en soi mais
perd le sommeil le plus doux il y a
aussi ces endroits ces lieux ces objets
qui appartiennent certainement odieux
mort fait puisque lorsqu'on s'y retrouve
envie de dormir s'empare de nous ça peut
être un hamac un simple mac dont le
mouvement régulier nous berce et faire
renaître en nous nos premiers sommeil
dans les bras de ne pas bien
un fauteuil
usés est particulièrement confortable et
qui nous ayant porté maintes fois et
accueilli de si nombreuses fois le
sommeil semble cette monnaie à notre
forme et nous apporter tout le confort
nous avions tout le confort dont nous
avons besoin
celles ci certaines émissions à la
télévision
la nuit qui remplissent notre esprit
image plus douce que d'habitude tu ne
vois plus qu'à chacun une émission série
un film qui lanta
c'est aussi ce sont aussi ces beaux et
qui nous font nous endormir chaque fois
peut-être le bris nation de la pluie
d'eau qui tombent sur la gouttière
peut-être le bruit de la respiration
d'un être aimé peut-être une musique
particulièrement tous et cannes
mélodieuse peut-être la voie d'un être
aimé peut-être aussi ce moment
merveilleux que l'on clinquant souvent
peut-être ce moment veilleux que l'on
connaît souvent quand on est plus jeune
lorsque l'on s'échange des secrets
rejetant la nuit il ya tous ces bruits
le bruit des grillons des cigales
de bruit du vent par les arts
le bruit de sa propre respiration si
régulière est si lente qu'elle pourrait
faire métronome et qui nous invite au
sommet de plus en plus est aussi bien
sur le son me voir qui va au fur et à
mesure de venir à madeco s'accompagnait
doucement respectueusement à mesure que
le corps et l'esprit ont maintenant
avancer pleinement vers le sommet de la
nuit à voile va reculer
je voulais c'est simplement la
possibilité d'être porté par le sommeil
alors les mots les sensations des
évocations donc le temps d'importance
car quelque chose de doux et de gamme
s'est installé en vous et s'endort
tranquillement bercé par la voix
bercé par le mystère de l'inconscient un
respiration
alors mes sont les rêves quelque chose
qui coulait courant nous comme une
rivière dans le refuge
celui du lit sa chaleur le confort du
client fin lorsque les mots presque vide
et la propre sang ce ne sont là que pour
être une sorte de mur mais une idée
jetée le timbre d'une voix qui vous gars
d'une infinie tout cela
d'une infinie entre train car le
souverain
emporté par l'erreur
autant tout par respiration lente par la
magie du sommeil qui vous qu'à foot
armés
le tarbais
dormez
sept séances de bien-être vous a été
proposé en partenariat avec le fit aux
nuits fit aux nuits en sachet à infuser
un mélange innovant de mélatonine
l'hormone naturelle du sommeil et de
cinq plants pour s'endormir et bien
dormir
bonne nuit avec le complément
alimentaire fit aux nuits